I used to be a coal miner, but now I’m a
full grown coal adult!
Hey there dirty dozens, Jules here for Dnews!
At the second presidential debate, Donald
Trump brought up clean coal.
Now, we saw some tweets from you guys wondering
what clean coal actually is!
But before we can explain clean coal, you
kind of have to understand why we use coal
in the first place.
Coal is incredibly important.
It's cheap -- one of the cheapest sources
of energy available.
It is amazingly efficient for making electricity,
and it’s one of the most abundant energy
sources in the world, even more so than oil.
But it has one huge drawback.
It is so dirty that people regularly die from
its pollution.
When coal is burned it releases chemicals
like sulphur dioxide, nitrogen oxides, a little
mercury, and carbon dioxide, not to mention
a bunch of various particulates.
These leak into the air and water and result
in smog, soot, acid rain, global warming,
and toxic air emissions.
Those can cause asthma, lung cancer, various
heart diseases, and other health problems.
Not good.
So, in an effort to placate people worried
about dying just to get a little electricity,
the coal industry heavily invested in clean
coal.
But Clean Coal is still coal.
It’s not a different kind of coal.
It’s just handled differently in the process
of turning it into energy.
The term Clean Coal is actually shorthand
for Clean Coal technologies, which are designed
to lessen the number of pollutants released
in the production of energy.
One such method is called carbon capture and
storage, which is exactly what it sounds like.
Carbon dioxide is separated from the air before
it leaves a power plant or other production
plant using a process called “absorption”
or carbon scrubbing.
This is where chemicals called amines are
used to bind to the carbon dioxide and pull
it out of the air.
This gas is then piped underground, or “sequestered”
so that it can’t leak into the atmosphere.
It can even be used to help depleted oil fields
coax their last bits of oil to the surface.
We have a whole video about CO2 scrubbing
if you want to know more.
Another popular method to end the infamous
acid rain scares of the 70s and 80s was to
wash all the sulfur out of coal before it
made its way into a plant.
And when I say wash, I mean literally, they
would break it down into chunks and run it
through a water tank which could include minerals
like magnetite to increase the density of
the liquid.
The coal floats, because it is less dense,
while the sulfur and other impurities sinks.
A third clean coal technology is called “oxy-fuel
combustion”.
When coal is burned at a power plant, the
exhaust, also called “flue gas”, is usually
just pumped into the atmosphere.
But oxy-fuel combustion actually reroutes
this flue gas back into the plant, where it
is paired with pure oxygen and reused to burn
more coal.
The reason they do this is because the normal
air we breathe air has a ton of nitrogen in
it, and when it’s heated with the coal,
it reduces its efficiency and creates more
nitrogen byproducts.
But when we reuse flue gas and combine it
with pure oxygen, this solves both of these
problems and allows for hotter temperatures
and more energy extraction.
There are a number of other methods, but despite
these efforts, environmental activists call
“clean coal” an oxymoron, since it’s
not quite the anti-pollution miracle that
coal companies make it out to be.
The problem is that these methods are incredibly
expensive and energy intensive, and that money
and energy has to come from somewhere.
Some estimate that the addition of capture
carbon and storage to a coal fire plant increases
coal use by 25% while keeping electricity
output the same.
Another huge problem is that these byproducts
aren’t so much being eliminated as they
are being moved elsewhere, which is more of
a storage solution than an environmental one.
And on top of all that, for those reasons,
clean coal technologies are not particularly
widespread, at least not enough to make a
significant difference for the time being.
In the end, clean coal helps stem pollution
at the source, but it seems to help coal companies
maintain their image more than it helps the
environment maintain itself.
If you've been a subscriber of DNews for a
while, you might've seen some of our recent
VR videos.
It's a completely new way to tell stories,
learn and experience the world, and we just
launched a brand new channel called Seeker
VR.
You can view the videos in 360 from your phone
or computer.
Click now to watch, or visit the first link
in the description.
And make sure you subscribe to Seeker VR.
So, coal burning can contribute to acid rain.
But we don’t really hear about acid rain
anymore.
We used to a lot in the 70s and 80s.
Is it still a big deal?
What ever happened to acid rain?
You can find out in this video here.
What other science issues have come up in
this election that you wanna know more about?
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to like and subscribe to DNews
for more video every day.